monsieur le Premier ministre je vous
souhaite la bienvenue je vous remercie
de vous être rendu disponible pour
répondre à nos questions dans cette
salle que vous connaissez très bien
Monsieur le Premier Ministre vous le
savez à partir du 10 juillet 2022
plusieurs membres du consortium
international de journalistes
d'investigations ont publié ce qui est
désormais convenu d'appeler les
hubert-files s'appuyant sur 124000
documents internes à l'entreprise
américaine d'été de 2013 et 2017 cette
enquête a dénoncé un lobbying agressif
de la société uber pour implanter en
France comme dans de nombreux pays des
véhicules transports et chauffeurs des
VTC venant concurrencer le secteur
traditionnel du transport public
particulier de personnes vous avez
jusqu'à leur au taxi dans ce contexte
notre commission d'enquête à deux
objectifs d'une part
identifier l'ensemble des activités de
lobbying menées par
uber pourra s'implanter en France le
rôle des décideurs publics de l'époque
et émettent des recommandations
concernant l'encadrement des relations
entre décideurs publics et représentants
d'intérêt et d'autre part pour évaluer
les conséquences économiques sociales
environnementales du développement du
modèle uber en France l'ubérisation et
les réponses apportées et à apporter par
les décideurs publics en la matière la
mesure où vous étiez ministre lors du
conflit entre les taxis et les VTC en
2014 après l'arrivée du beurre sur le
marché français vous avez accompagné
monsieur Théven puis monsieur
grand-guillaume pour résoudre ce conflit
nous est apparu essentiel de recueillir
votre témoignage d'une manière générale
ne souhaiterions connaître votre
appréciation des révélations des
uber-files et de l'implantation de la
société
uber en France et des VTC plus
généralement de façon plus précise
plusieurs questions nous intéressent
tout d'abord pouvez-vous nous rappeler
le contexte du premier conflit entre eux
les taxis et les VTC en 2014 lors de son
audition monsieur thévenou nous indiquer
qu'il n'y avait pas de stratégie
prédéfinies par le premier sous le
président de la République pour sortir
de cette crise lors de sa nomination
comme médiateur il indiqué qu'il avait
fallu discuter avec tous les acteurs
pour trouver une solution qui en
pratique c'est avéré plutôt
conservatrice protectrice pour les taxis
placé sous la responsabilité du
ministère de l'intérieur
alors que Bercy poussait plutôt pour
obtenir l'ouverture à la concurrence du
secteur avant même d'ailleurs motiver
d'Emmanuel Macron au poste de mise de
l'économie pouvez-vous nous confirmer
qu'au départ il n'y avait pas de
position de principe
quels étaient alors les relations entre
les différents ministres sur ce sujet
ministre de l'intérieur du tourisme des
transports de l'économie sur l'émergence
des plateformes VTC à l'époque les
positions de chacun étaient-elles
connues transparentes il y a eu lieu des
manœuvres des influences opaque des uns
ou des autres pour faire valoir leur
position que ce soit dans le cadre de la
discussion de la loi thévenou ou de la
loi quand Guillaume ou de la
réglementation
de ces lois l'autre sujet qui a animé
nos auditions et la question d'un deal
qui aurait été révélé par les luberfiles
se dit il aurait été préparé par
Emmanuel Macron avec vous et Manuel
Valls en juillet 2015 pour obtenir la
cessation du service uberpop en
contrepartie d'une réduction des
obligations de formation des VTC pour
les aligner sur les formations de
chauffeur de taxi pouvez-vous nous
confirmer l'existence ou non de de ce
deal nous aurons bien sûr d'autres
questions à vous poser mais je préfère
je vous propose d'entamer nos
discussions à ce stade je vous rappelle
monsieur le Premier ce qui s'est
audition est ouverte à la presse qu'elle
est retransmise en direct sur le site de
l'Assemblée nationale et avant de vous
laisser la parole je vous rappelle que
l'article 6 de l'ordonnance du 17
novembre 1958 relative au fonctionnement
des assemblées parlementaires impose aux
personnes auditionnées par une
commission d'enquête de prêter serment
de dire la vérité toute la vérité rien
que la vérité donc vous inviter à
activer votre myco lever la main droite
et dire je jure je le jure monsieur le
Premier je vous laisse la parole merci
beaucoup monsieur le Président Madame la
rapporteur je n'ose pas dire Madame et
Messieurs les Députés puisque je n'en
vois pas peut-être sont-ils derrière
leur écran bonjour à la député
je vais monsieur le Président essayer à
travers un propos liminaire de répondre
aux différentes questions que vous avez
posées et en même temps de vous
restituer mon témoignage concernant
cette période qui a vu effectivement les
chauffeurs artisans taxi les chauffeurs
de VTC et
les représentants des plateformes
s'affronter dans un cadre dont la presse
est largement féco et dont l'affaire des
hubert-féles a pu révéler certains
aspects je voudrais avant d'entrer dans
le vif du sujet de répondre à vos
différentes questions
replacer le sujet qui vous occupe dans
le contexte qui était le mien à l'époque
et nous étions confrontés à niveau de
menacéroïste extrêmement élevé nous
devions faire face à une vague
d'attentat au moment d'ailleurs où la
crise éclate de façon très visible avec
des incidents dans les aéroports et un
rassemblement des artisans taxis si j'ai
bonne souvenance
quelque part du côté de la Porte Maillot
qui justifie d'ailleurs que je réunisse
en urgence et représ entant de la
profession pour essayer de dénouer cette
crise les attentats de janvier 2015
c'était produit mais ceux qui devaient
suivre en novembre 2015 l'attentat du
Bataclan et la tentat des terrasses de
café n'avait pas encore eu lieu et nous
étions dans une préoccupation majeure je
le dis parce qu'il est important vous
ayez ça à l'esprit à l'époque au
ministère de l'Intérieur qui était celle
de la prévention du risque théorique
dans un contexte où nous avions perdu
beaucoup d'effectifs du fait de la
révision générale des politiques
publiques où nous n'avions pas encore pu
procéder à la reconstitution de la
totalité des moyens de nous avions
besoin pour faire face à cette crise
théorie nous avons recruté 9000 emplois
pendant la période 2012-2017 mais c'est
9000 emplois ont dû être formés dans les
écoles de police affectés au service de
renseignement et donc nous subissions de
plein fouet les effets de la RGPP sans
avoir nécessairement les moyens de
répondre à la totalité des missions qui
étaient des nôtres y compris en matière
de prévention et de contrôle terrorisme
pour des raisons qui tenaient à la
porride et des moyens dont nous
disposions pour les raisons que je viens
indiquer je le dis pourquoi parce que
c'est un élément de compréhension du
contexte moi je ne pouvais pas me
permettre comme isoler dans un contexte
de tension extrême où la responsabilité
de l'administration la tête de laquelle
j'étais la protection des Français de
dispenser un très nombre de forces qui
étaient rares du front antiterroriste
pour les mettre sur d'autres sujets je
devais bien entendu le faire si les
circonstances m'y obligés mais à chaque
fois que je j'avais à le faire cela
posait un problème une mise sous tension
de cette administration qui était déjà
très fortement
soumise à aux tensions résultantes de la
prévention de la lutte contre le théorie
que mon rôle à l'époque était de faire
en sorte que toutes les crises qui
étaient susceptibles de survenir
fusent dénouer avant qu'elle ne
survienne de manière à éviter d'avoir à
mobilisé ses moyens le deuxième élément
important c'est que je ne sais pas si ça
a été évoqué à l'occasion de vos
auditions mais
nous avions une réflexion globale sur la
sécurité dans les transports tous les
transports pour des raisons qui tenaient
à cette menace et qui nous conduisaient
à souhaiter dans le cas des dispositions
législatives et réglementaires en
vigueur qu'il y est une traça
de l'action des compagnies de transport
permettant de vérifier que aucun acte de
ses compagnies aucune opacité relative à
leur activité n'était de nature exposée
notre pays à un risque face auquel le
mobilisation tous nos moyens donc je
tenais à préciser ça en introduction
parce que je bien entendu je suis un peu
vos travaux m'attendant à ce que soit
amené à un moment ou un autre à y
participer mais pas avec le niveau de
précision qui est le vôtre et pour cause
et donc je ne sais pas si ces questions
ont été évoquées mais je paraissent un
élément de contexte détermine parce que
si on a passé à l'esprit on comprend pas
qu'elle était la position du ministère
de l'Intérieur concernant ce sujet le
deuxième élément sur lequel je voudrais
dire un mot en introduction c'est que
ces événements sont produits il y a plus
de temps pour moi maintenant
et donc je suis un âge auquel on a
encore la mémoire des choses mais avec
le temps qui passe sa terre
nécessairement et donc comme nous
n'avons pas accès à toutes les archives
les réponses aux questions que je vous
m'adressais ont bien entendu le niveau
de précision qui est celui de ma mémoire
et donc je ne suis pas sûr bien entendu
de pouvoir être aussi précis que vous
pourrez le souhaiter pendant le débat et
je m'en excuse par avance même si je
vais essayer de vous donner toutes les
informations dont je disais
ceci étant dit à l'introduction donc
quelques éléments sur le fond d'abord
quelques éléments sur les acteurs les
acteurs gouvernementaux d'une part et
les acteurs économiques d'autre part
pour ce qui concerne les acteurs
gouvernementaux il y avait quatre pôles
trois ministères et Matignon
les trois ministères vous les connaissez
je pense que vous allez en interviewer
les titulaires enfin en tous les cas
pour deux d'entre eux
le ministère de l'Intérieur le ministère
de l'Intérieur avait un rôle de
réglementation de la protection de la
profession de taxi depuis assez
longtemps
pour plusieurs raisons la première avec
la préfecture de police attribuée les
licences et qu'attribuant les licences
elle avait un rôle qui méritait d'être
contrôlé comprimé
la préfecture de police dépendante du
ministère de l'Intérieur une partie de
la légitimité du ministère de
l'Intérieur intervenir résulter du fait
que nous avions cette compétence
deuxième élément il pouvait survenir des
troubles à l'ordre public il en est
survenu et par conséquent le ministère
de l'intérieur était légitime à
intervenir dans ce qu'il y avait des
troubles de leur public pour les faire
cesser essayer de dénouer la crise c'est
ce que nous filme lorsque les tensions
sont apparues
troisièmement le mystère de l'intérieur
était amené à intervenir pour assurer le
contrôle des activités par
l'intermédiaire d'une unité particulière
les Bauer ce qui contrôlaient
le respect des réglementations vigueur
et à ce titre bien entendu nous avions
également une compétence et nous l'avons
exercée dans un contexte n'est pas très
simple parce que
j'y reviendrai la loi Novelli avait
augmenté considérablement le nombre des
acteurs intervenants sur le marché
notamment les VTC il fallait donc
multiplier les opérations de contrôle
RGPP était passé par là et nous n'avions
pas les effectifs dont nous avions
besoin pour conduire les missions avec
le niveau de d'acuité d'engagement qui
qui correspondait à mes souhaits mais
malgré tout nous le faisions et je crois
que nous l'avons fait efficacement j'y
reviendrai
ça c'était le premier ministère le
deuxième ministère était ministère des
Transports
qui avait un compétence plus
particulière sur la question des VTC
mais qui était une mission qu'il ne
détenait pas depuis très longtemps
puisque les VTC avait été créés quelques
années auparavant par la loi d'ovélique
et le mystère des transports avait eu un
peu de peine à s'emparer de cette
compétence et cette compétence a été
élargie dans le cadre du décret
d'attribution du ministre des Transports
au terme d'un remaniement ministériel
qui est intervenu en mars 2016 si j'ai
bonne souffrance mais cela pourrait être
vérifié vous devez pouvoir obtenir le
décret d'attribution pardon du
secrétaire d'État aux Transports en mars
2016 et à ce moment-là le ministère des
Transports a une compétence plus entière
sur la question des transports aux
personnes et notamment sur les aspects
de la formation puisque il a été décidé
dans le cas de cette crise de procéder à
l'harmonisation de la
formation des VTC des taxis
le troisième ministère compétent était
celui de l'économie
alors avant de parler du ministère
d'économie peut-être un mot sur la
posture ou
comment dirais-je la préhension par le
ministère des Transports le ministères
de l'intérieur de ces sujets le mystère
de l'intérieur était considéré par
l'ensemble des observateurs qui aimaient
follement la nouvelle économie
libéralisme comme un ministère de
conservateur de protection des taxis
en réalité le mystère de l'intérieur
était un ministère qui considérait qu'il
avait à faire une activité réglementée
que pour bien la réglementer il fallait
faire en sorte que les règles puissent
respectées par l'ensemble des acteurs
concernés ce qui dans un état de droit
n'est quand même pas fondamentalement
anormal donc non tout ce qu'on pouvait
penser le bruit de fond sur le
conservatisme des uns la situation de
monopole des autres etc nous nous étions
le ministère de l'État soucieux devant
les principes de l'État de droit
respecter et qui considérait que le
respect des principes de l'État de droit
était quand même la meilleure manière
d'éviter que le désordre ne s'instaura
vraiment
le ministère des Transports avait une
position encore en pointillée puisqu'ils
s'emparer d'une compétence que jusqu'à
présent il n'est pas eue et le ministère
de l'Économie des Finances avec une
compétence objective qui était celle de
définir les tarifs
de
d'accompagner sur le plan fiscal sur le
plan des mesures économiques un secteur
dont il considéré qu'il pouvait être
facteur de croissance et qui d'ailleurs
l'avait toujours fait dans une relation
un peu tendue avec le ministère de
l'Intérieur pour des raisons qui ne
tenaient pas aux personnalités des
titulaires du poste mais pour des
raisons qui tenaient à la matière dont
chaque ministère va connaître ce qui est
assez logique et compréhensible contenu
des compétences respectives que je viens
de présenter
et donc ce que je ressentais à l'époque
de la part de des ministres de
l'économie successifs un moment de
bourre d'une part et puis Emmanuel
Macron d'autre part c'est que les
ministres étaient sensibles
à la part de croissance que pouvait
permettre ses activités
et qu'ils étaient qu'ils étaient assez
désireux de prendre l'ensemble des
mesures fiscales et réglementaires qui
permettaient de créer de la croissance
et de l'activité
dans un univers qui n'était pas neutre
puisqu'il y avait une commission qui
avait sur cette question de la
libéralisation des transports aux
personnes et des taxis émis des
propositions la commission Attali et
qu'un ministre Hervé Novelli avait à
l'occasion d'une loi de libéralisation
pris des mesures en créant les véhicules
de transport avec chauffeur les VTC
VTC pour lesquels il avait donné une
impulsion forte mais sans préciser le
cadre dans lequel ces activités devaient
se développer nous étions donc avec la
loi du ministre Novelli dans un univers
qui était quand même plutôt
d'inspiration très libérale et qui avait
laissé énormément de zones grises et
d'imprécision
et la juxtaposition du statut
d'auto-entrepreneur d'une part et
d'autre part la création des VTC dans un
contexte où l'économie numérique évolue
rapidement et vite créer des conditions
pour toute une série d'acteurs de
s'engouffrer dans ces zones grises pour
essayer de faire pression et de faire
prospérer leurs activités voilà quel
était le contexte pour ce qui concernait
les ministères leurs compétences et
leurs relations pour ce qui concerne les
acteurs eux-mêmes il y avait bien
entendu les taxis
dont les plus libéraux considérés que
ils étaient représentés essentiellement
par une compagnie qui était en situation
de monopole je veux parler de la G7 donc
vous avez je crois auditionné le
président
la profession de taxi m'a paraissait
comme devons être modernisé
mais je n'avais pas d'interrogations
pour ce qui me concernait dans la
responsabilité qui était la mienne quant
à la capacité de cette profession à se
conformer rigoureusement au principe de
droit qui était élaboré par le souverain
en l'occurrence vous-même et précisé par
l'administration lorsqu'elle prenait ses
effets d'application c'est à dire que je
n'ai jamais été confronté et je n'ai pas
souvenir d'un incident
témoignant d'un manquement de la part
des taxis aux obligations réglementaires
ou législatives qui étaient les leurs
et donc
cette activité ne s'est présentée à moi
comme posant problème que dès lors que
le conflit est intervenu entre les VTC
des taxis puis entre les VTC les taxis
et les plateformes avec une montée au
paroxysme de la crise en juin juillet
et le deuxième catégorie d'acteurs
étaient les VTC donc les VTC avaient été
créés par
la loi Novelli avec le niveau
d'imprécision que je viens d'indiquer
concernant leurs obligations étaient
apparus des plateformes numériques
Hubert pop hitch qui avait pour objectif
de développer des services en créant les
conditions de la mise en relation
directe de chauffeur avec des clients
potentiels
mais dans une inégalité illégalité
totale puisque ces plateformes
intervenaient
en contravention absolue avec les règles
de droit qui devaient alors prévaloir et
c'était là le problème parce que dès
lors que il était possible de mettre
directement en contact par les
intermédiaires de ces plateformes de
géolocalisation des clients avec des
chauffeurs que cela se substitue à
l'activité de taxi qui ces contraintes
et que nous étions dans un univers sans
règles et dont les acteurs et notamment
les plateformes avec une stratégie que
je considère comme totalement cynique et
absolument inacceptable en état de droit
qui consistait à considérer que la
réglementation devait s'adapter à leur
business et non pas leur business
respecter leur réglementation il y avait
un problème de fond pour dire les choses
simplement tel était le sujet et donc
pour essayer de faire face à ce contexte
dans le cas d'une relation étroite avec
les parlementaires le gouvernement
auquel j'appartenais la majorité de
l'époque ont décidé de prendre un
certain nombre de dispositions ces
dispositions elles étaient de deux
natures des dispositions législatives à
réglementaires et des mesures de
contrôle par l'administration du respect
des règles en vigueur j'ai commencé par
les mesures législatives et je puis je
dirais un mot ensuite des dispositions
relatives au contrôle pour ce qui
concerne les mesures législatives le
choix qui avait été fait par le
gouvernement
moi je suis arrivé au mystère de
l'Intérieur en avril 2014 donc je crois
que les choses avaient été engagées par
tes genoux avant que j'arrive la loi
était promulguée le 1er octobre 2014
donc j'ai participé à une partie de ces
travaux à la dynamique et président
assez travaux mais pas la totalité je je
me souviens très bien que à la fois avec
le député Thévenot et avec le député
grand Guillaume l'idée était qu'on
coproduise une loi à travers un travail
parlementaire articuler un travail
gouvernemental et destinaire réguler une
activité la loi TV nous est une loi qui
a apporté un certain nombre de
modifications très enfin de précision et
de modification intéressante pour
essayer d'apaiser la situation
quels étaient ces modifications et
comment les choses sont-elles passées
d'abord une séparation assez claire des
activités de VTC taxi définissant ce que
chacune des catégories de transport
pouvait faire
la maraude est en réservée au taxi
les VTC étant dans l'obligation de ne
prendre des clients que dès lors que ses
clients avaient procédé à une
réservation les VTC en obligation de
produire le contrat les liant à leurs
clients et les plateformes de
réservation ayant vocation à être par
géolocalisation et en vocation à être
progressivement ouverte au taxi
des taxis eux bénéficiant d'une licence
qui les autorisait à stationner en
certains points des villes de leur
ressort territoriale pour pouvoir aux
stations de taxi prendre des clients
la loi Thévenot
prenant acte du fait que le nombre de
VTC augmenté et qu'il fallait réguler le
nombre de chauffeurs à introduit le
principe de la licence gratuite et
incessible les licences antérieures à
l'adoption de la loi TV nous continuons
à être Cécile et celle prise après
l'adoption de la lotte Evenou est en
gratuite et accessible parce que la
gratuité d'accessibilité des
licences étant sans doute la meilleure
manière de garantir la régulation de du
nombre global de chauffeurs tel était la
philosophie mais la loi était venue ne
comportait pas que ces dispositions elle
repose également sur d'autres mesures
qui étaient intéressantes et dans le
député était venu et le gouvernement
pensait qu'ils étaient ces dispositions
étaient utiles pour réguler l'activité
c'était la mise en place de terminaux de
paiement électronique pour les taxis
le développement d'une plateforme
numérique d'accès aux services des taxis
pilotés par l'État et notre notamment
le SMA que serait un général pour la
modernisation de l'action publique donc
c'est une maîtrise publique de ce
dispositif et la volonté de faire en
sorte également que cette loi fasse
l'objet d'une évaluation en termes de
son adoption dans le cadre d'une mission
d'inspection et un ministérielle à
laquelle devait participer l'inspection
générale de l'administration
l'inspection générale des finances et le
corps des contrôleurs du ministère de
l'équipement et des transports des
punitions interministérielles
ces dispositions n'ont pas suffi puisque
c'est en 2015 notamment printemps 2015
que la crise entre les VTC les taxis et
les plateformes atteints sont pas oxymes
pourquoi est-ce que cette crise
d'attention paroxysme parce que Hubert
et Hitch ne respectent absolument pas
les dispositions législatives adoptées
par le gouvernement et tout ce que nous
avons voulu faire avec la loi thévenou
ne pouvait être efficace que dès lors
que tous les acteurs se conformer à
leurs obligations
hyper pop et Hitch ne se conformant pas
à leurs obligations
nous avons été
nous dans l'obligation de prendre des
mesures législatives nouvelles c'est ce
que nous avons fait avec la loi
ganglions
et la loi ganguillaume nous a conduit à
introduire dans la loi tout ce que la
loi Novelli avait laissé
au hasard ou dans la précision
obligation pour les VTC de ce déclarer
précision de l'articulation entre le
statut de VTC ce qui résultait de la loi
d'orientation des transports intérieurs
adoptés au début des années 80 sous
l'impulsion d'un ministre qu'il n'est
pas libéral qui était Charles Peterman
si j'ai besoin dans cette époque et
cette loi Loti avait laissé quelques
imprécisions pour ce qui concerner le
transport collectif qui permettait au
VTC de prendre prétexte de cette loi
pour développer de l'activité de service
aux personnes en ont contournant
l'esprit et le texte donc la loi
ganglier aux mamie de l'ordre dans tout
ça en disant ce n'est plus possible de
continuer ainsi d'une part et d'autre
part tous ceux qui décident de faire des
activités de VTC doivent pouvoir le
faire dans la plus grande transparence
mise en place d'un registre obligation
de mettre en place une le témoigner de
la traçabilité de bien tendue de
l'obtention du permis de conduire mise
en place d'une assurance de sécurité
civile etc etc de responsabilité civile
pardon et puis mise en place d'un outil
très très important qui manquait
cruellement puisqu'il n'y avait pas
d'impact où elles étaient très
lacunaires lorsqu'on prenait à
disposition législatives sur ce sujet la
mise en place d'un observatoire dont
j'ai compris à travers nos travaux que
considériez qu'il avait mis du temps à
se mettre en place si toutefois il s'est
mis en place alors qu'il est
bon donc voilà ce que la loi ganglion a
apporté mais
[Musique]
tant de tempérament normand est
considérant qu'une grande confiance doit
jamais exclure une petite méfiance et
que la confiance c'est que lui pas le
contrôle nous avons développé une
activité très forte de contrôle par
l'état des acteurs concernés
j'ai dû un peu les comptes rendus de vos
auditions il m'est arrivé de dire que
l'État n'avaient pas fait ce qu'il
fallait pour faire respecter la loi je
veux porter témoignages devant vous que
c'est tout le contraire et en apporter
la démonstration
nous avons à travers une circulaire
interministérielle du 24 juin
2015 donc qui est une circulaire qui a
été rendue publique et signé des
ministres concernés compétents avant la
réunion du 25 le 25 j'étais à Marseille
je suis rentré précipitamment à Paris
pour tenir une réunion de concertation
avec les taxis contenus de la l'ampleur
que prenait la crise et le 24 cette
circulaire interministérielle est une
circulaire qui appelait les préfets à
intensifier les contrôles
par l'intermédiaire des forces de police
notamment des bords sur les
professionnels de respectant pas leurs
obligations
et de le faire
à travers une action qui concernait
l'ensemble des acteurs concernés les
taxis pour ceux qui concernaient leurs
obligations
en matière de mise en place des
terminaux de paiement électroniques
les
VTC pour ce qui concernant pour ce qui
concernait le respect de la maraude
monopole des taxis et les plateformes
pour ce qui concernait
le non-respect par elle de toutes les
dispositions législatives en vigueur
puisque nous respectait aucune et donc
il fallait taper très fort
le Garde des Sceaux avait pris une
dépêche pénale
extrêmement précise dont je pense que
votre mission à le texte
le texte se dépêche pénal du garde des
sceaux du 23 juin 2015 les extrêmement
intéressantes parce qu'elle rappelle
toutes les infractions au travail
dissimulées toutes les infractions au
manquement par les plateformes de leurs
obligations légales et appels les
procureurs de la République enclenché
les poursuites et par ailleurs j'avais
pour ma part déclenché à l'article 40
auprès du Procureur de la République de
Paris
Arctic 40 fondée sur le constat que qui
avait été fait par nos services du
non-respect par
Hubert de ses obligations
donc je vous dis tout ça pourquoi parce
que il y a des lois
je vous en prie madame
est-ce que vous pouvez préciser s'il
vous plaît les éléments invoqués dans la
le recours à l'article 40 justement la
nature des infractions
je vais comme je veux être extrêmement
précis je regarde si j'ai dans mes
documents cet article 40 je dois la voir
et auquel cas je vais vous donner les
éléments de façon extrêmement précise
sinon je vous le je vous le
communiquerai si je ne l'ai pas là mais
enfin le
je pense que je dois pouvoir récupérer
ces éléments
c'était l'ensemble c'était en réalité
l'ensemble des infractions au travail
dissimulé
au non respect
des dispositions concernant la maroose
c'est-à-dire la possibilité pour les
chauffeurs du Berre de prendre
directement des clients alors même qu'il
n'avaient pas la possibilité de le faire
le non-respect des zones de
stationnement qui devaient rester
monopole des taxis en réalité ce que
faisait les gens de les
chauffeurs du beurre pop à la demande du
Berre pour être très clair c'était de
créer les conditions d'une tension
maximale pour essayer de créer le plus
grand désordre afin de faire en sorte
que le droit évolue en leur faveur la
stratégie était assez simple c'était
cela donc pour atteindre cet objectif là
on ne respectait pas la maraude on
utilisait dans des conditions qui
étaient tellement contraires au droit du
travail des des collaborateurs dans des
conditions d'opacité donc la presse est
fait largement l'écho et dont l'affaire
des humains révèle l'ampleur et donc moi
mon objectif c'était de faire en sorte
que tout ce qui est relevé de la
législation relative aux transports aux
personnes et tout ce qui relevé du
travail dissimulé fut sanctionné donc
c'était ça le contenu de mon article 40
ayant constaté que tout cela n'était pas
respecté et estimant qu'il était du rôle
de l'État de faire en sorte que cela fut
respecté nous prenions des dispositions
pour que
l'époqueur les magistrats agissent mais
enfin vous pouvez vous avez bien entendu
accès à ces documents moi je vous
donnerai au terme de je les retrouverai
je vous donnerai ces éléments
qui sont par ailleurs publics donc nous
avons été extrêmement ferme et moi je
l'étais avec une détermination totale
parce que j'étais
ulcéré par le comportement du Père
je ne pouvais pas accepter comme isoler
sans doute consubstantiel à la fonction
mais c'était aussi tout à fait conforme
à mes convictions que des sociétés
étrangères liés aux grands gaffes
américains viennent sur le territoire
national alors qu'il n'y payait aucun
impôts et j'ai rarement déjà social pour
imposer un droit qui était conforme à
leurs intérêts en bafouant aux yeux de
tout le monde le droit voté par le
souverain et dont l'État avait en charge
l'application et les instructions qui
ont été données par le ministère et
j'étais assez remonté d'ailleurs je
crois que
dans les articles qui ont fait état de
l'affaire hubert-five le représentant du
père explique les mots désagréables que
j'ai pu avoir à son encontre je l'ai
confirme en tout point
pour une bonne et simple raison c'est
que pour moi il n'y a pas de négociation
avoir avec ce qui en freine la loi si on
se met à voir des négociations avec ceux
qui en freinent la loi ça veut dire
qu'il n'y a plus d'État de droit donc
je réponds à votre question sur le deal
il n'y a pas eu de Deal auquel j'ai
participé sur ce sujet parce qu'il y a
pas de deal à avoir avec des acteurs qui
étaient financièrement puissant estimé
qu'ils avaient à se placer au-dessus des
lois
donc la réponse est très claire je n'ai
participé à aucun deal d'aucune sorte et
de toutes les façons il n'était pas
question qu'il en fut autrement contenu
de la conception que je viens d'évoquer
de l'action qui était la nôtre et que
j'ai rappelé et qui est traçable
je vais aller plus loin dans la réponse
est-ce qu'il y a eu de la part du
gouvernement un moment donné un terme
ministériel évocation d'un deal vous
additionnerez d'autres membres du
gouvernement à ma connaissance jamais et
jamais dans mes conversations avec le
Premier ministre avec le ministre de
l'économie et des finances avec le
ministre des Transports a été évoqué un
deal de cette nature d'ailleurs s'il y
avait eu quelconque qui m'aurait été
proposé j'en aurai refusé jusqu'au
principe hors de question
faire dernière partie de ce qu'il faut
comprendre quand même ce qui se passe
pourquoi est-ce que malgré tout on
évoque un deal alors que il y en a pas
eu
cette question se pose enfin tous les
cas moi je peux vous assurer qu'il y en
a pas eu
il pouvait pas y avoir un deal sans le
ministre de l'intérieur ça ça me
paraissait quand même un peu compliqué
et
je pense que
[Musique]
il y a sans doute eu des discussions
entre le ministre de l'économie et des
finances et les représentants de la
nouvelle économie
il y en a eu d'ailleurs entre eux et moi
qui n'ont pas qui n'ont pas été mal
elles n'ont pas été nombreuses
et tu viens d'avoir une ou deux par
téléphone et la deuxième dans mon bureau
où les choses se sont pas bien passées
en juin
2015 ou les choses ont été dites façon
extrêmement ferme puisque je leur ai
demandé de procéder à l'arrêt des
activités illégales sans aucune
contrepartie il y a pas de contrepartie
à l'arrêt d'une activité légale où il
n'y a plus d'État de droit si on accepte
de raisonner ainsi donc les choses ont
été actées puisqu'ils sont cessés leurs
activités
est-ce que
dans d'autres ministères il y a eu des
discussions avec eux j'imagine
qu'il y en a eu aussi puisqu'ils avaient
plus de raison de les voir que je n'en
avais moi-même
mais à aucun moment avec le ministre de
l'Économie des Finances de l'époque à
aucun moment avec le Premier ministre il
a été question d'un quelconque d'île
voilà donc je tiens très clair là-dessus
parce que ça correspond à la réalité des
faits auxquels j'ai été confronté
lorsque j'étais au gouvernement voilà ce
que je voulais vous dire en essayant
d'avoir répondu à vos questions et
subirai bien entendu à répondre à toutes
les autres que vous souhaiterez
m'adresser
merci monsieur le Premier j'ai quelques
questions je vais revenir sur certains
des points de votre exposé qui était
très
approfondie
mais d'abord je voudrais vous poser
peut-être une question plus générale
est-ce que vous considérez arriver à la
fin du mandat en 2017 que les pouvoirs
publics ont réussi à trouver un bon
équilibre entre le respect de l'ordre
public de la régulation l'accompagnement
de ces nouveaux acteurs avec ces deux
lois tu es venu et grand Guillaume
bon d'abord quelle était la politique la
politique c'était une politique de
modernisation des taxis à laquelle les
taxis eux-mêmes n'étaient pas hostiles
sous réserve qu'on leur donne la
garantie que cette politique de
modernisation n'était pas une politique
de
destinée à dissimuler une volonté de les
faire disparaître donc nous ne voulions
pas faire disparaître les taxis nous
voulions qui se modernise nous voulions
que l'offre globale aux citoyens
souhaite améliorée et nous considérions
que l'offre globale aux citoyen pouvait
pas être améliorée dans la dérégulation
absolue de cette activité et j'étais
personnellement absolument convaincu de
cela et tout à fait hostile à une
politique de déréglementation de
dérégulation telle qu'elle avait été
engagée par Novelli et telle qu'elle
pouvait être souhaitée par un certain
nombre d'acteurs à Bercy dans
l'administration parmi je ne le
souhaitais pas bon et donc oui nous
avions un débat sur ce sujet
et nous avions un débat parfois vif sur
ce sujet sur d'autres pour des raisons
qui tenaient au fait que ils pouvaient y
avoir des désaccords entre nous c'est
des accords étaient très traités dans un
cadre interministériel par le Premier
ministre avec une stratégie qui était
modernisation refus de la dérégulation
complète et amélioration de l'offre
aux clients voilà quelle était la
stratégie et c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous avons mis en place ces
dispositions législatives est-ce que
lorsque nous partons nous estimons que
nous avons atteint le but non parce que
le chantier est ouvert encore
faut avoir le la tête de le dire
l'ensemble des dispositions
réglementaires d'applications des
dispositions législatives n'ont pas été
prise notamment pour la loi grand
Guillaume parce que le processeur
ministériel est tendu
ensuite les dispositions n'ont pas été
prises
et par conséquent le dispositif n'est
pas encore totalement stabilisée de ce
fait
moi j'ai quand même été très frappé
alors que ce n'était pas mon domaine le
coeur de mon domaine de compétence
c'était plutôt un sujet qui relevait du
développement de l'activité économique
de constater qu'on avait pris beaucoup
de dispositions législatives sans
véritable enquête d'impact et outils de
d'évaluation de ce qui était le secteur
on peut il y a eu beaucoup d'idéologie
dans cette affaire quand même et assez
peu de d'analyses objectives de ce qui
était le contexte et la situation et
d'ailleurs la lenteur avec laquelle
les choses se sont améliorées et la
difficulté à mettre en oeuvre
l'Observatoire préconisée par la loi
gangliome montre bien que l'idéologie
avait peur des faits
et que ceux qui étaient dans une
approche très libérale
était assez peu enclin à créer les
conditions d'un examen objectif de ce
qui était la réalité du service et donc
non quand on nous partons moi je suis
convaincu que l'équilibre de la
politique est bonne mais que beaucoup
reste à faire pour faire en sorte que
cet équilibre aboutisse
à ce que nous souhaitions quand je
regarde les choses avec recul et en
ayant plus toutes les informations dont
je disposais à l'époque j'ai quand même
le sentiment que les taxis se sont
vraiment modernisés que leur pérennité
n'est plus mise en cause qu'un nouveau
service est développé à leur côté qui
s'est malgré tout
installer
et que l'équilibre auquel la politique
que nous voulions que nous mettons en
oeuvre voulait parvenir a quand même
globalement été
consacré par les faits même si beaucoup
reste à faire
alors il y a un point je n'ai pas évoqué
qui me paraît fondamental
et qui était un irritant pour le mystère
de l'intérieur et pour moi c'était les
conditions de travail des
des personnes employées par les
plateformes ou je devrais plutôt dire
exploiter par les plateformes
nous avions
[Musique]
merci
je voudrais revenir sur la question du
deal que vous avez mentionné
pardon j'ai pas entendu monsieur je vais
revenir sur la question du deal est plus
précisément vous l'avez mentionné
brièvement sur le débat de
l'harmonisation des formations entre les
chauffeurs VTC et taxi donc on a cet
arrêté du 2 février 2016 relatif à la
formation et à l'examen du conducteur de
voiture de transport avec chauffeur qui
est signé en interministériel par des
représentants de la ministre de
l'Écologie du Développement durable du
ministre de l'intérieur par délégation
le magistrat délégué interministériel la
sécurité routière déléguée à la sécurité
et la circulation routière monsieur
barbe et une représentante du Ministère
de l'économie est-ce que vous pouvez
nous parler un peu du contexte de cet
arrêté et de des raisons qui ont poussé
à cette volonté d'harmoniser les
conditions d'accès à la profession de
chauffeurs VTC des chauffeurs de taxi
oui merci de cette question parce
qu'effectivement on parle de Deal mais
je n'ai pas précisé sur quoi aurait
porté le deal donc si je comprends bien
le contenu des informations qui ont été
diffusées
il y aurait eu la suppression du beurre
pop contre partie de quoi il y aurait eu
un accord sur la formation et le deal
c'était ça
alors pour ce qui concerne la
suppression du père pop
elle était inconditionnelle nous avions
engagé toutes les procédures que je
viens indiquer les tribulots Français
étaient saisis
le tribunal c'était prononcé en octobre
2014 il devait voir sa décision première
instance confirmer une année plus tard
Hubert avait multiplié les procédures à
l'encontre de la loi thévenou en allant
jusqu'à soulever une question
prioritaire de constitutionnalité donc
il espérait qu'elle ruinerait tous les
efforts législatifs et pouvoir le
gouvernement pour réguler le secteur il
n'en a rien été et donc
mon analyse et qui correspond
la réalité c'est que c'est la
multiplication des actions conduites par
l'administration pouvait respecter les
dispositions législatives qui aboutit à
la suppression du berpop j'ai d'ailleurs
eu l'occasion de dire
façon très nette ou responsable du père
que s'il ne cessez pas cette ses
activités alors qu'elle était illégale
nous je le tiendrai comme
personnellement comptable de ne pas
l'avoir fait alors qu'il était de leur
responsabilité de faire cesser cette
idée égalité et j'en ai profité pour
matérialiser la détermination qui était
la nôtre à faire respecter le droit donc
il n'y a eu sur ce sujet
aucune contrepartie à ce qui encore une
fois relever de l'application de la loi
pourquoi est-ce qu'il y a pas eu de
contrepartie parce que s'il y avait une
contrepartie ça aurait une signification
bien plus grave que l'île
ça aurait la signification Corée une
contrepartie et pour moi c'était
inacceptable c'était vous êtes en
contravention avec le droit vous voulez
mettre le droit en conformité avec vos
intérêts aux motifs que vous êtes
financièrement puissant et pour bien
vous montrer que nous sommes faibles
nous allons faire un deal ça c'est
inacceptable si les choses fonctionnent
ainsi ça veut dire qu'il y a plus d'état
de droits donc pour moi ça n'était pas
concevable donc
voilà alors ensuite sur la formation
sur la formation
je j'ai cherché à
préciser très finement ce qui s'était
passé les différentes étapes pour
comprendre qu'elle avait été le
cheminement donc avant la loi TV nous
inexistait pas de formation spécifique
pour les vétés en France pour la bonne
saint présence que la loi Novelli je
l'ai dit était une loi qui était une loi
d'imprécision elle avait créé un produit
un projet un objet mais n'avait
aucunement défini les règles
s'appliquant à cet objet et la formation
des chauffeurs de taxi était régie par
un texte 2009 qui établissait les
conditions à la d'accès à la profession
de chauffeur de taxi et définissez les
modalités de formation pour les
candidats mais le texte sur les taxis ne
fixés je le précise aucun minimum
d'heures qui fixé des principes généraux
la loi thévenou a instauré une formation
obligatoire un examen pour les
conducteurs de VTC dont les conditions
et les modalités devaient être précisées
par un texte réglementaire c'est
l'arrêter de février 2016 qu'il le fait
donc de nombreux mois après que
l'activité a cessé et qui établit la
et ce texte là
a été abrogé quelques mois après en
avril 2017 par un arrêté du sac avril
la loi grand Guillaume et ses décrets
d'application vise à créer les
conditions d'une harmonisation entre la
formation des VTC la formation des
chauffeurs de taxi pourquoi
parce qu'il y avait une demande
conjointe si je me souviens bien des
deux professions les VTC étaient formés
par des organismes de formation privée
les chauffeurs de taxi étaient pour leur
part formés par les préfectures et il a
été décidé au terme d'une discussion que
ce serait la Chambre nationale des
artisans qui procéderaient désormais à
la formation à une formation harmonisée
et aujourd'hui
outre l'examen d'accès à la profession
de chauffeur de VTC ou taxi et depuis un
arrêté qui date d'août 2017 c'est à dire
après notre départ du gouvernement
relatif à la formation continue du taxi
du VTC tout chauffeur devait tester
Texier tenue de suivre un stage de 14
heures minimum tous les 5 ans
donc les dispositions
relatives
à la formation et aux nombreuxeurs de
formation qui prévalent aujourd'hui ont
été arrêtés après le changement de
gouvernement et de majorité de président
de la République pas avant
et donc avant que le quinquennat se
termine la seule disposition qui a
vraiment prévu c'est la disposition
d'harmonisation des modes de formation à
travers l'émergence de la Chambre
nationale des artisans et
l'harmonisation à 7h
ultérieurement passé à 14h sur 5 ans
merci j'ai une dernière question a
Priora des questions de rapporteur
peut-être de collègues et nous aurons à
déborder un peu au-delà de l'heure
je voulais vous demander
si vous avez parlé de désaccord de débat
idéologique qui était exprimée en
interministérielle est-ce qu'en tant que
ministre de l'Intérieur puis Premier
ministre vous avez le sentiment que
votre autorité sur ces sujets a pu être
entravé ou contourné
dans de façon opaque
au-delà de l'interministériel et du
travail
gouvernemental classique par d'autres
acteurs du gouvernement
moi dans les fonctions qui étaient les
miennes à l'époque je n'ai pas senti de
d'opacité j'ai senti de la frontalité
tout ça que j'ai senti c'est-à-dire que
je n'étais pas d'accord avec le ministre
de l'Économie des Finances sur un
certain nombre de sujets
nos cabinets se le disaient lorsque
l'occasion nous était donné d'en parler
je l'exprimais pas le seul sujet sur
lequel j'étais désagré avec le désaccord
avec le ministre de l'économie et des
financiers veulent également la réforme
du permis de conduire
j'avais mis en place une réforme le mise
à l'économie et des finances c'est
emparée de ce sujet lorsqu'il est arrivé
il a voulu aller beaucoup plus loin dans
la libéralisation du passage du permis
de conduire que je ne la vie envisagé
nous avons eu une discussion difficile
enfin c'est pas Dieu à la personnalité
du président à la mienne même si nous
avons chacun notre personnalité et que
nous avons l'habitude de lire les choses
c'est vieux comme le mystère de
l'intérieur le mystère de l'économie je
suis convaincu que si vous reprenez les
discussions qui ont eu lieu entre Michel
Alliot-Marie Hervé Novelli au nom de la
réforme si vous les interrogez vous
aurez des positions assez semblables
donc moi je n'avais pas d'opacité dans
ma relation avec le ministre de
l'Économie des Finances même si les
discussions qu'il avait avec Hubert j'en
avais pas connaissance il y avait de la
frontalité c'est-à-dire que nous
n'étions pas d'accord et nous nous le
disions et le Premier ministre dont
c'était le rôle arbitrer ses différents
merci Monsieur le Premier Ministre ah il
faut éteindre votre
vous avez eu une phrase extrêmement
forte pour moi vous dites on ne négocie
pas avec ceux qui en feraient une loi
et pour vous il n'y avait en aucun cas
de dire et il n'y avait pas matière
entre guillemets à négocier quoi que ce
soit avec des plateformes qui ne
respectent pas les professions
réglementées tout un cadre tout un tas
de cadres légal puisque il y avait
plusieurs plusieurs enfin plein de
registres différents de nos respects de
l'État de droit
avez-vous donc été surpris par les
révélations des uberphales ce qui montre
qu'au contraire pendant ce temps
Emmanuel Macron alors ministre de
l'économie avait énormément
d'échanges bien souvent direct y compris
par SMS les journalistes parlent de
notamment 17 échanges significatifs
c'est à dire qu'il y en a bien d'autres
entre le ministre et où sont cabinet et
des dirigeants de duber de l'époque
avez-vous été surpris c'est-à-dire
est-ce que vous en tant que ministre de
l'intérieur
lorsque en discussion interministérielle
ou en réunion de conseil des ministres
vous échangez sur le dossier est-ce que
vous avez connaissance de ces relations
extrêmement rapprochées entre Emmanuel
Macron et les dirigeants du Berne
notamment Travis calanic ou bien le
lanceur d'alerte
Marc Magan
il s'avère que j'exerçais plusieurs
responsabilités ministérielles pendant
les 5 ans du quinquennat de François
Hollande j'ai été mis du budget j'étais
mise à faires européennes et j'ai été
mise à l'intérieur depuis le premier
ministre donc il m'est arrivé de voir
des acteurs économiques
je dois d'ailleurs reconnaître
qu'il est très difficile de diriger un
état sans en rencontrer jamais aucun
et que le fait de rencontrer un acteur
économique
quel que soit la sensibilité que l'on a
si c'est considéré comme une faute
morale je souhaite bien du courage à
ceux qui seront amenés à exercer la
responsabilité de l'État dans les années
qui viennent donc la question n'est pas
de savoir si on rencontre des gens la
question est de savoir ce que l'on fait
lorsqu'on en compte bon est-ce que le
ministre de l'économie était victime à
rencontrer les gens du père 17-18-19
fois 20 fois la question n'est pas de la
bonne question dans la vie n'est pas
celle là la question est est-ce que la
rencontre entre le ministre économie et
les gens du père comme d'ailleurs la
rencontre que je pouvais avoir moi avec
les gens du Berre ou avec les gens de
Jésus a été de nature à infléchir la
position de l'État concernant les
obligations qui étaient les siennes
le sentiment que j'ai c'est que non
puisque lorsque nous avons eu
à
prendre des dispositions très dures à
l'égard du bien nous les avons prises
dans l'état d'esprit que j'ai indiqué
parce qu'il ne pouvait pas y en avoir
d'autres et que quel que soit la
sensibilité qu'on peut avoir il m'a pas
échappé que le ministre de l'économie de
l'époque avait une sensibilité beaucoup
plus libérale que la mienne et qu'il les
rencontrer pour les ai rencontrés pour
développer la nouvelle économie mais que
cela ait pu conduire à des décisions de
l'État qui soit contraire à ce que les
devoirs de l'État lui dicté ça ce serait
très malhonnête en vous disant que j'ai
vécu les choses ainsi alors même que
toute mon action a consisté à ne pas
laisser un millimètre d'espace à ses
acteurs dont je détestais les pratiques
j'ai eu à faire d'ailleurs à ces acteurs
sur d'autres sujets ce n'est pas
inutile de le rappeler à la commission
lorsque nous sommes confrontés au cri à
la crise terroriste et que dans les
heures qui suivent les attentats le
nombre de messages appelant au
terrorisme antisémite anti-musulmans
anticatholique
augmente de 73% sur les plateformes
numériques et que je n'arrive madame la
député à obtenir aucune décision de
retrait de la part des plateformes
qu'est-ce que je fais on aurait pu me le
reprocher je me rends dans la Silicon
Valley rencontrer les présidents de
toutes les grandes sociétés numériques
en leur disant ce que vous faites est
inacceptable et je le veux et d'ailleurs
lorsque je me rends aux États-Unis pour
dire aux représentants des sociétés
numériques ce que vous faites il
acceptable et si vous ne changez pas de
comportement il y aura de toutes les
façons des dispositions extrêmement
dures prises par le législateur parce
que c'est inacceptable je suis reçu
avant cette visite par le ministre de
l'Intérieur américain et le mission de
américain qui me disent bon courage vous
êtes
bien emblématique de l'analyté française
vous n'obtiendrez rien et en avril 2015
c'est à dire deux mois après nous
signons le premier accord avec les gafam
par lesquels il s'engage à retirer les
les contenus et nous passons de 73% de
33% pardon de retrait à
73-80% de retrait donc moi je n'ai
jamais j'ai toujours considérer
sur ces sujets que le fait de parler à
des acteurs pour leur dire ce qu'on
avait à leur dire dès lors qu'on avait
une certaine conception de l'État et de
l'intérêt général était nécessaire et je
termine en disant que le quinquennat
auquel j'ai participé est un quinquennat
qui a pris des disposition qui n'avait
jamais été prise en droit français pour
réguler l'action des représentants
d'intérêts jamais et je suis
particulièrement fier d'avoir été le
Ministre ayant porté ses disposition au
bord du gouvernement la loi d'octobre
2013 et la loi décembre 2013 relative à
la transparence de la vie publique à la
lutte contre la fraude fiscale et
la grande délinquance financière ont
instauré le PLF ont instauré la Haute
autorité pour la transparence de la vie
publique la loi Sapin dans son article
25 à réglementé l'activité des
représentants d'intérêts donc non
seulement la conception que nous avions
était celle que je vienne indiquer mais
toute l'action législative que nous
avons eu à l'époque
a consisté à encadrer l'activité des
représentants d'intérêt pour que ces
dérives que vous redoutez à juste titre
ne puisse pas se produire donc voilà
quel a été notre action
alors vous précisez à exclusivement
votre micro s'il vous plaît
vous précisez bien qu'elle a été le sens
de votre action lorsque vous étiez
ministre de l'intérieur
et en aucun cas
mon propos n'est de dire que le ministre
de l'économie de l'époque n'avait pas
avoir à avoir de contact avec des
grandes entreprises et notamment
des plateformes comme Hubert ce qui est
intéressant c'est de voir la nature de
ces contacts et sur quoi elle repose je
reviendrai sur la question du deal dans
un deuxième temps
les révélations des hubert-files font
état des changes des SMS entre notamment
Marc Magan
l'obéissent de chez Hubert et Emmanuel
Macron notamment le 21 octobre 2015
sur des
réactions notamment de Marc Magan qui
interpelle le ministre par SMS et lui
dit nous sommes concernés par l'arrêté
préfectorale à Marseille interdisant
uberx service VTC nous avons appris cela
par lifep et avons informé notre votre
cabinet pourriez-vous demander à votre
cabinet de nous aider à comprendre ce
qui se passe
respectueusement Marc la réponse par SMS
reçue par Marc Magan d'Emmanuel Macron
est la suivante je vais regarder cela
personnellement faites moi passer tous
les éléments factuels et nous décidons
d'ici ce soir raison calme à ce stade je
vous fais confiance il va y avoir un
premier arrêté puis un deuxième arrêté
pris par le préfet des Burges du Rhône
de l'époque Monsieur Nunez actuellement
préfet de Paris le premier arrêté
ciblait un certain nombre de
localisations enfin de lieux où
le nombre de VTC dépendant du Berre
était particulièrement nombreux et poser
un véritable problème de concurrence
déloyale pour les taxis et susciter la
colère des taxis notamment aux alentours
des gares et des aéroports il est quand
même souvent on est souvent ainsi
l'arrêté en soi le premier comme le
deuxième disait pas plus que simplement
une fois appliquer la loi c'est ça mais
donner un sens le premier arrêté en
donnant les les zones géographiques
donnaient un sens vis-à-vis des taxis
que nous allons mettre comme vous le
disiez les effectifs de police pour
contrôler la situation et donc face au
taxi qui était très mobilisé à ce
moment-là sur le terrain il me semble
que vous étiez en déplacement
à ce moment-là aussi de ce fait là de
cette mobilisation c'était un signal
fort pour les chauffeurs de taxi quand
tu es arrivé le deuxième arrêté qui lui
ne spécifiez plus les localisations et
parlait juste de l'ensemble du
département comme il aurait pu dire
l'ensemble du territoire de la
République car les lois s'appliquent sur
République
pour les taxis ça a été une terrible
déception et ils ont le sentiment
d'ailleurs que dans les jours qu'on
suivit il n'y a pas eu les mêmes
contrôles
qu'il pouvait espérer ou qu'il y avait
pu avoir un moment donné par le passé
et par contre
pour
pour Hubert ce sera une considérée comme
une victoire ce deuxième arrêté est-ce
que vous avez été en contact avec le
préfet Nunez à l'époque sur ce
changement de ces deux arrêtés
comment réagissez-vous par ailleurs
au SMS d'Emmanuel Macron vous a-t-il
sollicité par la suite ou avez-vous
connaissance qu'il est plus sollicité le
préfet Nunez avez-vous pu avoir le
sentiment en découvrant ces éléments là
lors des révélations
uber-files que le ministre de l'économie
de l'époque ne vous tenait pas forcément
au courant des engagements oraux qu'ils
pouvaient prendre vis-à-vis du Berre
mais là je pense que vous serez tout à
fait rassuré d'apprendre que les SMS que
le ministre de l'Économie envoyait des
tiers n'arrivait pas directement sur mon
portable
donc je ne recevais bien entendu pas
les SMS que Emmanuel Macron envoyer des
tiers fort heureusement sinon
je pense que je ne serai pas devant une
commission d'enquête parlementaire mais
devant d'autres instances c'est pas
comme ça qu'on fonctionne l'état donc
les SMS que
Emmanuel Macron voyait à d'autres
c'était d'autres qui les recevaient en
aucun cas moi et je n'en savais rien
est-ce que j'ai eu un contact avec
Emmanuel Macron sur cet arrêté
absolument pas j'avais pas en avoir
d'ailleurs s'il m'avait contacté sur cet
arrêté au motif kuber ceci ou vers cela
le ministre de l'économie en dépit de
tout le respect que j'avais pour lui
aurait été reçu
nous avions une certaine franchise de
relation ça ne se passait pas comme ça
nos relations j'avais une responsabilité
il en avait une
j'estimais que mon rôle était de faire
en sorte que tous les principes de
l'État de droit fusse à chaque instant
respecter et je n'aurais pas du tout
aimé recevoir un message de cette nature
et c'est d'ailleurs la raison pour
laquelle sans doute je ne l'ai pas reçu
ensuite pour ce qui concerne l'arrêté je
pense que si vous avez l'occasion de
d'interroger le hanunès vous pour lui
poser la question de savoir les raisons
pour lesquelles l'arrêter a été modifiée
mais comme je souhaitais que nous
puissions intervenir sans la moindre
faiblesse à l'égard du Berre et que
l'attitude procédurière du père était
bien connu
vous avez vu l'ensemble des procédures
qu'ils ont engagées je n'entendais pas
qu'une procédure du Berre à l'encon d’un
arrêté puis affaiblir l'État et
consacrer la victoire du Berre donc les
conseils que je donnais et les consignes
que je tenais à mes collaborateurs et
Laurent Nunez était un collaborateur
c'était vous prenez des arrêtés si vous
avez le sentiment
vous les prenez en ayant procédé à
l'ensemble des vérifications en droit
qui vont bien si vous avez le sentiment
que le contenu d'un arrêté naturel
fragilisé en droit n'offrait pas cette
victoire à Hubert voilà qu'elles étaient
mes consignes est-ce que c'est la raison
pour laquelle la réalité a été modifiée
je le crois mais comme tout cela remonte
à un certain nombre d'années et que je
n'étais pas moi-même l'auteur de
l'arrêté une interrogation de rendu là
sur ce point serait de nature à vous
apporter toute garantie
mais vous imaginez bien la député que
quand on a affaire à des acteurs aussi
plus scrupuleux que celle que ceux que
nous avions en face de nous et dont les
procédés étaient absolument cyniques et
sans scrupule on ne leur offre aucune
occasion de victoire en droit aucune et
d'ailleurs quand vous regardez les
décisions qui ont été prises par le TGI
par les instances d'appel par le Conseil
constitutionnel vous pouvez remarquer
que toutes les dispositions législatives
et réglementaires que nous avons prises
ont laissé à Hubert assez peu de prise
puisque les victoires du maire devant
les tribunaux ont été éthiques au sens
nul
j'entends d'argumentation mais vous
comprendrez que à l'époque pour les
chauffeurs de taxi ils se sentait
reconnu comme profession réglementée
défendue en cela par votre Ministre et
par le ministère des Transports et
s'il n'avait pas connaissance à quel
point les liens entre le ministère de
l'économie et les dirigeants du Berre
étaient auto si proches et ils l'ont
découvert par les hubert-félize ils
avaient bien compris que l'orientation
idéologique du ministère de l'Économie
de l'économie Emmanuel Macron était en
faveur de la dérogation y compris de
leur secteur et pour une un soutien à
cette uberisation agressive qui se
développait
et que cette question des deux arrêtés a
été vécue totalement autrement du point
de vue
du point de vue des acteurs en question
les ans ayant considéré que le deuxième
arrêté était une victoire les autres au
contraire que c'était un renoncement pas
à contrôle
quoi qu'en disent en termes
d'explication le préfet monsieur Nunez
que nous avons auditionné sur la
question du deal passé entre Macron et
kalic
Travis calanic le terme de deal a été
celui d'Emmanuel Macron dans les dans
les révélations du bafile c'est lui qui
utilise ce terme qu'il est arrivé à un
deal il y a notamment en janvier 2015
une deuxième rencontre entre 13 calanic
et manuel Macron
où on a certes tuber qui est confronté
par les enquêtes judiciaires pour
travailler dissimulé où il y a des
arrestations de chauffeurs du bar pop et
suite à cette deuxième rencontre les
éléments que nous avons parlés
sont les suivantes un dirigeant
l'obéiste du Berre qui était présent à
cette rencontre à sa deuxième rencontre
à Bercy envoie un compte rendu aux
avocats de de l'entreprise
il parle de d'Emmanuel Macron il est
favorable à une licence light pour les
VTC et par conséquent un élément un
allégement significatif des conditions
requises renforcées par la loi TV
et l'objet du deal donc va être on s'est
mis d'accord avec Emmanuel Macron sur un
process en deux temps un proposer un ou
plusieurs amendements à la Loi Macron
avant demain soir afin de modifier la
réglementation actuelle introduite par
la loi donc une volonté d'essayer de de
torpiller de déconstruire en fait la loi
de nous deux nous avons une fenêtre de 4
semaines pour mener une campagne de
communication avec Macron afin de faire
accepter l'idée qu'une licence VTC Lite
serait une solution pour l'emploi et la
mobilité dans ce contexte il s'agira de
trouver le moment opportun pour rédiger
un décret abolissant le régime proposé
par la loi thévenou et introduire une
réglementation plus souple ce que je
commence à à comprendre sur toutes ces
périodes c'est que nous avons des
ministères très attachés à l'état droit
ministère de l'Intérieur ministère des
Transports le Premier ministre de
l'époque je pense prends-tu nous nous
l'interrogerons et un ministère de
l'économie qui pense nécessaire par
disruption par choix idéologique de
déréglementer très fort bon jusque là la
limite c'est un débat politique au
Premier ministre de tranchée et au débat
parlementaire de pouvoir en transparence
délibéré sur la définition d'intérêt
général le problème c'est que la
démultiplication des rencontres entre
Emmanuel Macron et les lobby de Blair
sont dans l'opacité la plus totale ne
sont pas inscrits dans les agendas ils
ne sont publics de personnes et on sent
qu'il y a une volonté y compris stratège
y compris manœuvrière de la part du
cabinet de et de l'équipe du ministre de
l'économie de l'époque pour imposer un
débat avec un réseau de députés qui vont
défendre des amendements et tout cela
dans une opacité sur la stratégie par
exemple des amendements nous avons
auditionné du vélo et au regard des
documents qui étaient en entre
connaissance transmis par consensium de
journée des journalistes et on voyait
bien que par exemple certains
amendements qui étaient notamment pour
remettre en cause le retour au garage
des chauffeurs VTC certains amendements
il avait été acté entre l'équipe du
Berre et l'équipe de Macron que le
ministre de l'Économie donne rien à vie
défavorable donc il s'agissait
d'amendement entre guillemets pour faire
un leurre pendant que se préparer la
légende de la formation
c'est à dire que pendant que vous aviez
des ministères qui faisaient appel à
thévenou puis par la suite à grand
Guillaume pour essayer de trouver un
compromis le plus respectueux de l'étape
de droit et répondait aux enjeux et bien
on avait quand même une autre stratégie
de la part d'Emmanuel Macron est-ce que
vous pouvez vous
que pouvez-vous dire de ce qu'il se
décidait entre vous et de la
connaissance que vous aviez sur toutes
ces stratégies notamment de manœuvre par
le biais de parlementaire
bon d'abord je ne pouvais avoir à
connaître que ce que ce qui relevait de
mes compétences ou que des réunions
auxquelles je participais par la force
des choses je ne pouvais pas connaître
de ce qui m'était étrangers et ça valait
à l'époque ça vaut aujourd'hui encore
deuxièmement
j'ai lu qu'il y avait toute une série
d'amendements clés en main qui avait été
préparé à l'attention de parlementaire
qui les avait pris une extenso j'ai été
dans cette maison pendant très grand
nombre d'années
je trouve ces pratiques
très contraires à la conception qui est
la mienne du rôle de parlementaire parce
qu'un parlementaire il porte des
considérations d'intérêt général il peut
bien entendu recevoir des gens c'est pas
interdit avec la loi s'appelle l'article
25 de la loi Sapin et les règlements mis
en oeuvre au sein des assemblées les
choses ont beaucoup changé depuis c'est
très bien nous l'avons voulu et nous
avons eu raison de le vouloir contenu
des pratiques qui ont été révélées et
dont vous venez de faire état dans votre
question
donc tout cela est existé c'est c'est
fort possible mais même si tout cela a
existé tout ça ne pouvait pas échapper à
la manière dont se conçoit le travail
législatif dans un état qui fonctionne
normalement je m'explique
lorsque tu une série d'amendements sont
préparés et maintenant de parlementaire
ou qu'il s'agit évidemment de mon
gouvernementaux un texte de loi aussi
important que celui que vous faites
auquel vous faites référence il y a une
mécanique interministérielle qui se met
en place cette mécanique
interministérielle conduit le cabinet du
Premier sur l'ensemble des sujets dont
le Parlement aura à connaître à arrêter
la position que le ministre prendra au
banc du gouvernement donc
même si le ministre de l'économie et des
finances avaient
l'intensité de
l'activité qui est décrite dans les
articles et vous venez d'évoquer toutes
les façons le ministre de l'Économie des
Finances n'aurait pas pu échapper à la
logique interministérielle parce que moi
j'étais pas d'accord avec cette
orientation
mes collaborateurs étaient autour de la
table lorsque l'addition est un
ministérielle se prenait à mettignon le
ministre des Transports que de l'époque
il y en a eu deux première partie ça
devait être fabriqué ensuite à la vie
d'Alice avait leur propre opinions donc
Emmanuel Macron n'était pas encore à la
tête d'un dispositif totalement vertical
qui le conduisait à décider de tout à
tout moment il était ministre parmi
d'autres
et donc
même si Emmanuel Macron avait voulu à ce
moment-là avec les Hubert-Félix faire
tous les deals du monde il n'aurait pas
pu les faire seul
et il aurait eu en face de lui des gens
qui s'y seraient opposés pour toutes les
raisons que j'évoque depuis le début de
cette audition et à aucun moment il
n'aurait pu au banc du gouvernement
si l'État veut fonctionner normalement
il a fonctionné normalement ma
connaissance donner un avis à un
amendement parlementaire qui n'aurait
pas fait l'objet
d'un accord
du gouvernement décida en
interministériel parce que c'est ainsi
que fonctionne l'état quel que soit ceux
qui dirigent l'État c'est ainsi qu'il
fonctionne sinon il fonctionne
sur sur l'histoire de cet amendement et
de la vie défavorable du ministre
comprenait la manœuvre en fait
révélée par les journalistes il s'agit
pas de dire que la vie du ministre
d'économie et était contraire à celle du
gouvernement bien au contraire mais
qu'il s'agissait à un moment donné deuil
d'une organisation de manœuvre poussée
des amendements néanmoins avoir des avis
défavorables sur ces amendements
conformément à l'intérêt du gouvernement
pour pouvoir
montrer des menaces possibles dans
l'hémicycle sur une certaine orientation
et mieux faire passer un compromis sur
sur la formation en tous les cas c'était
visiblement des stratégies de manoeuvre
qui n'avaient pas été
qui était resté dans l'opacité que ce
soit y compris même pour les porteurs
d'amendements les députés porteurs
d'amendement et a priori vous me le
confirmez du point de vue du point de
vue du des différents membres du
gouvernement
c'est totalement contraire à la
conception de ville de la Cinquième
République à laquelle on reproche
parfois d'être très fortement attaché
ça c'est de la tambouille
et ce que j'ai vécu au sein du
gouvernement lorsque j'y étais c'est que
il y avait un dispositif qui protégeait
l'état de toutes
tentation tambouillarde c'est le
processus interministériel portant une
vision d'intérêt général et je n'ai pas
vu pendant cette période
quel que soit ses orientations ses
souhaits politiques sa volonté
disruptive etc le ministre de l'Économie
et de l'époque échappé à la logique Adam
mystérieuse je mentirais si je vous
disais que je l'ai que j'ai vu autre
chose que un dispositif interministériel
s'appliquant correctement alors que ces
manœuvres étaient existé etc à ça
pouvait être très attaché un
fonctionnement normal de l'État souhaité
que ce soit des mesures des
considérations d'intérêt général qui
préside au positionnement de l'État et
n'avoir aucune naïveté à l'égard de
de la manière dont les choses peuvent se
passer et je vous confirme que je n'ai
aucune naïveté mais le dispositif de
fonctionnement de l'État sous l'autorité
du Président de la République et du
Premier ministre à l'époque à mon avis
était de nature à éviter que le
dispositif ne dérape en tous les cas
c'est le sentiment que j'en ai eu
j'entends
mais vous comprendrez que l'objet de
cette commission d'enquête est quand
même néanmoins de s'attacher à
l'ensemble des révélations du bafal ce
qui montre une énorme opacité dans
toutes ces relations et ses échanges
alors certes nous sommes à ce moment-là
avant la loi Sapin 2 donc il n'y a pas
d'obligation
même si je pense que on doit regarder
aussi c'est fait là au regard de la loi
Sapin 2 pour se dire est-ce que la loi
ça part deux aurait pu garantir moi
d'opacité plus de transparence et on
voit aussi du coup et nous sommes nous y
travaillons ardemment à toutes les
insuffisances du décret d'application de
la loi Sapin 2
donc opacité tambouille et par ailleurs
avant de donner la parole à ma collègue
vous avez été
très très attaché à montrer que l'État
droit
était respecté ou en tous les cas il y
avait pas de manquement de l'État à
faire respecter l'état droit je pense
qu'il y a eu une véritable volonté
affichée c'est reconnue par les acteurs
concernant votre ministère néanmoins
vous pourrez reconnaître que
la loi grand Guillaume d'abord la loi TV
nous puis la loi grand Guillaume de fait
n'ont pas été appliquées et ne sont pas
appliqués en intégralité
qu'aujourd'hui par exemple
concernant l'objectif de réservation
préalable et la nécessité de retour au
garage pour les chauffeurs VTC ces
choses-là ne sont pas appliquées dans
dans les faits est-ce que vous ne pensez
pas que dans la stratégie de lobbying du
Berre
l'utilisation du bear pop
et le maintien du berpop après la
première décision du judiciaire
lorsqu'il faut appel et avant qu'une
intervienne l'arrêté qui sera pris et
qui mettra fin à
l'appli effectif même si à profite
judiciaire d'ailleurs elle est toujours
pas close elle a toujours elle est
toujours en cours est-ce que vous ne
croyez pas que
uberpop a servi un peu de revenant de
moi à en rigoler pas trop mais de
drapeau de chiffon rouge pendant que
finalement Hubert pouvait continuer à
s'implanter sur
sur le territoire c'est-à-dire que il
fait en sorte Hubert fait en sorte qu'on
se préoccupe énormément du maire pop les
chauffeurs de taxi sont excédés par
Hubert pop cayle vraiment le le
l'extrême des régulations et pendant ce
temps Hubert continue alors que
l'application classique Hubert elle
aussi contrevient au à l'état droit sur
bien des domaines et résultat les
décisions que l'on prend enfin on fait
interdire uberpop mais les décisions que
l'on prend comme un compromis notamment
sur l'abaissement de la formation
maintienne aussi Hubert en développement
et dernière chose aujourd'hui vous avez
dit une phrase très forte aussi sur le
fait que vous souteniez la directive
européenne en débat sur la présomption
de salariat
aujourd'hui pensez-vous que cette
directive devrait faire l'objet d'un
débat à l'Assemblée nationale puisque
aujourd'hui la position de la France n'a
pas été rendue entre guillemets publics
et débattu par les mains parlementaires
sur cette directrice de salariat or nous
savons que les discussions en toute
opacité entre les lobbies et les
décideurs publics se poursuivent ne se
sont absolument pas arrêtés et que c'est
aussi l'objet de notre enquête
parlementaire dans
d'éclairer cela
alors il y a plusieurs questions dans
votre question la stratégie du Berre la
stratégie du Berre était
d'assainissement total
elle consistait à multiplier les fronts
de façon agressive et disruptive pour
obliger l'État à modifier sa
réglementation de sorte qu'elles
deviennent favorables aux intérêts du
berce qui était inacceptable et
ce qui me paraissait être
souhaitable pour contrecarrer cette
stratégie était
de ne rien laisser passer à Hubert sur
aucun sujet ni sur uberpop ni sur le
non-respect des dispositions
législatives à réglementaires pour
concernant les activités qui ne
relevaient pas du père pop ni sur les
conditions d'exploitation des personnes
par Hubert car quand on voyait la mettre
le temps de travail des chauffeurs du
bear pop et ce qui leur restait après
avoir travaillé des heures durant dans
des conditions de dérèglementation
totale c'était absolument inacceptable
au regard de ce que sont les principes
du droit donc vous avez je pense que
vous avez raison sur ce qui était la
stratégie du beurre c'était
effectivement ce que vous dites il y a
une stratégie cynique tozazimu destiné à
obtenir la déréglementation la plus
totale pour permettre non pas au
salariés
au chauffeur du père de pouvoir
prospérer au terme de cette
déréglementation et pour permettre à
Hubert de continuer à faire son business
sans acquitter ses charges sociales et
sans payer d'impôts en France puisque il
avait il avait une petite activité en
France qui ne justifiait pas d'une
assiette fiscale permettant la
fiscalisation de la totalité des revenus
engendrés par son activité ce qui
n'était absolument pas le cas des taxis
les taxis payés leur impôts en France il
faut quand même le rappeler
donc oui cette stratégie était celle-ci
c'est la raison pour laquelle j'étais
dans l'état d'esprit que je vous ai
indiqué c'est-à-dire ne rien laisser
passer sur aucun sujet
et que quel que soit le gouvernement qui
aura à faire face à ces sociétés
internationales qui possèdent ainsi il
aura de toutes les façons à témoigner de
la même fermeté sur tous les sujets
quels qu'ils soient
donc je partage votre diagnostic et
c'est parce que je partage le diagnostic
que l'action que nous avons conduite a
été dans l'esprit que j'ai indiqué pour
ce qui concerne le débat l'Assemblée
nationale
je veux pas m'élever au dessus de ma
condition moi je ne suis plus
dans cette maison j'ai plus de
responsabilités gouvernementale
le principe que j'aurais tendance à
défendre c'est que il n'y a pas de débat
dans cette hémicie qui soit inutile
et ces questions paraissent suffisamment
essentielles pour que un Parlement comme
celui de notre pays puisse être amené à
en débattre bien entendu ces sujets sont
fondamentaux ils sont les sujets par
lesquels on parviendra dans les années
qui viennent à maintenir des activités
dans des conditions de respect des
droits des salariés qui soient
suffisantes pour éviter leur
exploitation
par des acteurs dont on a mesuré le
cynisme
merci je veux laisser la parole à notre
collègue madame rouleau
bon bah est-ce que vous pouvez proposer
vos deux questions en même temps
peut-être à ce moment-là et comme ça on
laisse le Premier ministre répondre et
conclure je vais essayer d'être rapide
merci merci monsieur le ministre vous
avez été extrêmement clair néanmoins
j'ai encore du mal à comprendre comment
en français on peut laisser perdurer des
pratiques illégales puisque vous avez
dit devant cet état de fait les
solutions étaient de deux ordres d'ordre
législatif en premier et d'ordre
administratifs en seconde donc si j'ai
bien compris on a adopté une loi la
première loi la loi de thévenou pourquoi
en fait on ne pouvait pas pourquoi on
était parce qu'en adoptant cette loi en
fait on reconnaît un état de fait on
laisse les VTC
voilà donc on est surpris moins en tant
que citoyen lambda je suis surprise
qu'une réglement que une pratique
perdure au point qui faille une loi pour
l'empêcher et donc pendant ce temps elle
perdure pour qu'on arrête pas tout de
suite qu'est-ce qui fait que on
les empêche pas de pratiquer voilà ça
c'était ma première question parce que
vous êtes très attaché à l'état de droit
comme je le suis
deuxième chose est-ce que dans la loi
thévenou qui était là pour apaiser vous
avez dit on la prend pour apaiser est-ce
que dans la loi tu es venu il était
prévu une quelconque indemnisation pour
les chauffeurs de taxi puisque certains
ont vu la valeur de leur licence chuter
de de moitié et certains se sont
suicidés est-ce que pour apaiser
justement la loi était venue à imaginer
si la Panini imaginé pourquoi le
problème d'indemnisation des licences
bon d'abord nous n'avons pas laissé
perdurer une situation illégale puisque
Hubert pop a été fermé puisque des
actions ont été déclenchées contre
Hubert au terme de démarche notamment
initié par des membres du gouvernement à
la faveur de du déclenchement d'article
40 que
des tribunaux ont pris des décisions qui
ont été confirmés par les instances
d'appel
donc on peut pas dire que rien n'a été
fait puisque au contraire toute l'action
que j'ai rappelé était dessinée par la
loi et par l'intervention de
l'administration à préciser le cadre
juridique et lorsqu'il n'était pas
respecté à faire cesser l'activité
pour ce qui concerne l'indemnisation
j'avais sur l'indemnisation des des
chauffeurs dont la valeur de la licence
avait considérablement décrue du fait de
l'arrivée des VTC sur le marché en
sachant que la licence était
l'équivalent pour les chauffeurs de taxi
d'un fonds de commerce pour des
commerçants c'est-à-dire qu'il est un
élément de leur patrimoine retraite on a
oublié ça mais c'était un élément
déterminant
sur le plan des principes je trouvais
que le fait que l'État avec de l'argent
public Vienne compenser des pertes de
ressources
résultant
du non-respect des dispositions
législatives à réglementaires par des
acteurs privés
était quand même un sujet qui qui
méritait débat et
ça méritait débat et donc
il fallait plutôt réguler l'activité des
transports aux personnes pour que les
licences ne perdent plus de valeur et
même reconstitue leur valeur et de ce
point de vue là ce qui a été fait avec
les licences accessibles gratuites
étaient de nature pour les licences qui
avaient été acquises de permettre
de maintien de leur valeur
éventuellement leur revente plutôt que
de voir
l'état avec l'argent public veut dire
compenser pour le compte
des artisans ce qui résultait de la
spéculation et du non-respect de la loi
par des acteurs privés dont on
connaissait les marges et éventuellement
qu'on mette en place un fond dans les
médiation payée par eux-mêmes paraissait
bien plus bien plus censé que de mettre
en place à fond d'indemnisation publique
monsieur le Premier ministre je vous
remercie de votre témoignage votre
présence et de l'exhaustivité de de vos
réponses si nous avons des questions
complémentaires je pense que nous vous
les ferons parvenir et puis bien entendu
n'hésitez pas à revenir vers notre
commission d'enquête si vous voulez
vous-même apporter des précisions ou des
éléments complémentaires puisque nous
continuerons à travailler jusqu'en
juillet et intervalle je vous remercie
infiniment et je vous souhaite une
excellente journée